ce sondage incroyable neuf femmes sur
dix préfèrent que les hommes fassent le
premier pas
neuf femmes sur dix alors en mots
pourquoi pas ce qu'il ya après de
timidité 40% peur du rejet 42% et en
trois parties roger cas où dur je
m'interrogeais sur
moi c
est enfin elle a craint d'être perçue
par les hommes comme une fille facile ça
c'est pour isabelle
j'ai toujours détesté faire le premier
j'avais passé fin de toute façon pour
faire le premier pas c'est la bd lors
bonjour donc à rim a justement j'ai
mangé je me suis arrêté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est compliqué parce qu en fait
personne me drague à bombay tôt non mais
je te préviens mais bon comment ça se
fait mais les hommes ne viennent pas
vers moi je sais la prévenant tout ça
c'est bien de rails ça vous allez
continuer de sources non plus une femme
est plutôt belle en fait les hommes ou
le déni peur parce que je suis ils ont
peur
c'est une citadelle imprenable devrait
jamais périr j'ai passé douze ans avec
le père de mes enfants même un peu plus
et je lui ai dit c'est bizarre on m'a
toujours dit que faisait peur aux hommes
et le débat moi tu me fait pas peur je
dis bah
alors vous vous aimez vous les préférez
quoi ben moi je pense être dans le 1 sur
10 parce que en fait c'est moi qui aime
draguer si je suis intéressé et en fait
je pense que ça d'ennahda c'est un peu
le principe si on n'est pas guéri je
veux dire c'est les nanas qui
choisissent parce que quand tu as quand
quelqu'un vient nous bright et âme qui
choisit tout à fait ouais et quand un
homme vienne draguer forcément des eaux
là il est lourd où il est intéressé au
machin tandis que quand c'est des filles
qui choisissent au moins c'est sûr que
ça va se faire non moi je suis plutôt
dans le main sur vous
[Musique]
je vais faire moi y aller
pas du tout d'accord avec delphine je
pense que oui effectivement on choisit
mais si un homme bien nous draguer déjà
ça peut être très bien fait avec
beaucoup d'humour beaucoup de
bienveillance et puis je peux dire non
aussi quoi vous rigolez
alors suivi huit vous
n'aviez pas un peu les deux ça dépend ça
dépend du si je suis si j'ai un peu bu
si je suis un peu pompette ouais je peux
y aller sinon je suis plutôt timide et
réservé sur une question
avec eux on dit que dans la communauté
c'est plus facile les relations d'hab
voilà que chez nous c'est une façon on a
un contact plus facile on sort plus
facilement et puis voilà on d'abord on
va voir quelqu'un pour s'amuser pu
apprécier le contact et là ça se passe
bien dans mon milieu mais moi vous savez
je suis casé
pour la pêche le frigo est plein couvre
pas les restaurants
de permettre une remarque sociologique
ou pas alors alors sur lui dit logique
ça vous employer un mot peut-être
parce que c'est compliqué si une femme
se draguent tu vas dire elle a fait ça
avec combien de mecs donc ça va faire
peur aux mecs parce que tu vas croire
que c'est une allumeuse et qui a fait ça
avec tout le monde et ses chants des
fois d'aller draguer baisse il permet au
gym bah oui ça veut dire que si le mec
qui fait ça avec une femme nous on a
droit de cité vous avez dit avec combien
de femmes battues
[Rires]
donc quand c'est la femme c'est une à
l'humeur et quand c'est là
également on va nommer on va demander un
spécial
s'amarrer absolument incroyable
incroyable c'est bien sûr y ait besoin
non tout ça très mauvais en dragon la
bombe est justement de ta vie sexuelle
mois alors allez allez trépidant ouais
y'a pas mal d'actuels
de demain vous pourrez me questionner de
quoi exactement je dîne avec des filles
ce soir mon genre mais
deux ans j'ai mis deux ans à dîner alors
attendez il ya est dans le coup
alors dans le sondage est une bonne
nouvelle des deux films ya quand même
une femme sur deux qui pense qu'il est
normal que l'homme raidh l'addition à 76
pour kaba oui maman et son papa
j'attends mieux merci
[Applaudissements]